Apple's new M3 iMac is finally here and
it's essentially pretty much what we all
expected except for a couple of things
that would have really made it exciting
but no apple kept it simple and
basically disappointed a lot of US tech
nerds but don't worry guys Apple
refreshed all of the literally identical
iMac marketing materials on their
website with brand new wallpapers yay
Jokes Aside the reality is that apple
target market for this iMac is the
complete opposite of you and I Apple
cares about the regular folks who could
care less about specs the ones that
simply decide to walk into the Apple
Store one day and buy a new Mac for
their home office so in this video I'm
talking directly to you techies out
there because some of you are probably
sitting there with your old 27in Intel
iMac honestly getting tired of waiting
for the new iMac Pro Pro with a larger
more multitasking capable display so
what I'm going to answer in this video
is if you should finally pull the
trigger on this new M3 iMac with the
24-in display or wait even longer for
that larger iMac so let's get started
the good news is that the new iMac still
has the same $1,300 starting price as
before but you need to proceed with
caution because the M3 chip does in fact
come with a Bend 8 core G puu at the
base price which didn't show up in the
new M3 MacBook Pro so some people
thought that Apple was no longer binning
the base chip but they are for the iMac
and another difference is that Apple
this year gave the M3 MacBook Pro 512
gigs of SSD storage at the base price
which basically means it comes with two
nand flash storage chips which I've
confirmed by looking at this tear on
shot from Apple's October event Kino and
this essentially means that they've
fixed the issue that happened on the
base model M2 MacBook Pro which only
came with a single nand chip which
basically ruined the speed of the memory
swap SSD feature which essentially
ruined multitasking performance and made
it slower than the old M1 MacBook Pro in
a variety of cases but unfortunately the
new base 24-in iMac does in fact come
with only 250 6 gigs of storage which
means that it likely only has a single
nand chip so if you love multitasking
and doing productivity work at the same
time you'll likely see a performance
drop compared to the old M1 iMac in that
case you're probably going to want to
upgrade to 512 gigs of storage to avoid
any issues and get those dual nand chips
as well as upgrading to that 10 core GPU
and getting those two extra ports and
gigabit either net but now you're left
with a
$1700 price tag but wait Apple didn't
give the M3 chip 12 gigs of RAM like we
speculated so we're stuck with only 8
gigs which many agree isn't enough for
techies so you've got to upgrade that as
well so now the question becomes is the
new 24in iMac with the M3 chip worth
spending
$1,900 on but before I get into that
I've got to talk about protonvpn from
our sponsor proton which hides your IP
address and fully secures your data
while browsing the web including their
integrated ad blocker net Shield which
also stops online trackers it's used by
privacy conscious individuals around the
world allowing many people to safely
browse the web and access banned social
networks but let's be real most of you
will probably be using it to stream
movies shows and even play games that
are restricted or banned in your country
proton VPN is easy to use fast and has
over 2900 servers in over 60 countries
and right now you can get up to 60% off
the 30mon plan for proton's Black Friday
deal so you'll only pay $3.99 per month
so check out protonvpn using the links
in the description below now getting
back to the question of if the new 24-in
iMac is worth spending $1,900 on sure
you now get all of the New Media engine
features like av1 decode and a bunch of
GPU features to trace all of your rays
as well as Wi-Fi 6E and Bluetooth 5.3
but not much else has changed you've got
the same display as before the same
speakers the same single external
display support and yes the same
lightning magic peripherals instead of
getting updated to USBC which was the
one thing that we all wanted but no it's
basically the same iMac as before with
the same colors but with M3 so here is
my honest advice if you're looking at
this iMac from a consumer perspective
just getting a reliable all-in-one
desktop Mac that's simple to set up and
use for your home office for regular web
browsing business related work and a
solid homework and YouTube machine for
your kids then simply buy the base model
for $1,300 and call it good now if
you're a tech and you care about all the
performance and other upgraded features
then I would steer you away from this
iMac and point you to two different
options number one would be to
absolutely buy one of the new M3 MacBook
Pros based on how much budget you have
seeing as the base M3 model is a killer
value for what you get with the new
beautiful 14-in redesign number two
would be to keep waiting for that larger
iMac because yes we've been seeing
multiple reports that apple is still
working on it both from Mark German and
Mii quo first of all quo recently
updated his prediction to state that the
higher-end 32in mini LED iMac Pro isn't
coming until
2025 which hints at it being based on
the M4 family of chips and yes he
believes it's going to have a 32in
massive display now last year mark
German believed that the new larger iMac
would come with M3 Pro and M3 Max chips
which would imply that we could see them
as soon as the spring of
2024 however he has recently updated his
predictions mentioning that early work
has been started on an iMac with a
display larger than 30 in and when he
words things like this it usually means
a product is a couple of years away so
with that said we might not actually see
the iMac Pro until 2025 now in my
opinion even though I'm going against
the leaks I think it actually makes
sense for Apple to create two more large
iMacs the first one would be a 27in iMac
which has a design that's identical to
the 24in design except that it would be
thicker while still being proportionate
due to the larger size this one would
likely come with the option of an M3 or
M3 Pro chip or if that's not enough M3
Pro or M3 Max and it would all once
again be inside of the chin which would
now be thicker and longer due to the
larger display size because of that
there just might not be enough thermal
Headroom in the chin for the M3 Max but
who knows and then a bit later down the
line Apple would release the massive
32in iMac Pro which would come with
let's say the M4 Max and maybe have the
option of the M4 Ultra this one is not
going to have a chin being an edgo edge
display design similar to the pro
display xdr and the the only reason I
think it'll be possible for it to get
the M4 Ultra is if Apple releases the M3
extreme chip in the Mac Pro which is
basically four Max dieses put together I
know this is just wild speculation for
now but I do want to point you guys to
the iMac prototypes leaked anonymously
on Mac Rumors forums showing that Apple
was testing multiple 27in Apple silicon
IMAX and my point is that if Apple
originally plan to only have a 32-in
iMac Pro then why even consider testing
so many 27in prototypes unless they want
to have a regular 27in iMac but anyway
answering the original question my
advice is that if you need a reliable
all-in-one computer for your home office
or for your kids just get the base iMac
model and get an upgrade or two if you
really want but for those who need more
performance either get the new M3
MacBook Pros or keep waiting for the
higher end IMAX that are bound to come
within the next couple of years so if
you enjoy this video go ahead and
subscribe above for our indepth testing
next week and check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one